hi Rebecca hi Mark
what's going on
I know it's kind of uh
how are you doing mark I've been fine
given questions for me today or I'm
sorry give me questions for me today I
don't even know what to ask anymore
relax
I was trying to put you in touch with
your friend farida
who you grew up with but you
didn't show up here at 10 o'clock this
morning
what time is that
2 30.
really
you're a couple hours late
I'm sure you had something to do man
I was uh
so um
should we take off the glasses
sure
um
laughs
all right
I know what you want out
I'm sorry I don't know what do you wanna
I don't know I don't think there's
anything to talk about
it is there
we're just documenting your spiral
downward
um
[Music]
laughs
I know go ahead ask me anything
you're closer to your dad than your mom
right
you can call your dad
I love my dog but
honestly I love my mom
oh you haven't spoken to either of them
in how long
uh
it's been a minute maybe
how many years has it been
I'm not really so sure
hasn't really been here as honestly
ah
foreign
what else do you want to ask me about I
don't even know
you still have the phone I got yesterday
no I got in a bit of a hiccup honestly
and I was kind of
[Applause]
so why do I keep buying you these phones
when you lose them within hours
[Music]
if you get me on today I promise I won't
lose that I'm sorry if you got me on
today I promise I won't lose up
you've already lost about 10 phones
within hours every one you lose within
six hours of me giving it to you
it's not
no it's true
foreign
what else do you want to talk about
please go ahead I don't know
I'm just not in the mood for
for this spiral
I feel like we're just chasing our tail
no so true
laughs
if you like anything is moving in a
positive direction do you think anyone's
even trying to move it in a positive
direction
honestly I I do in a sense who's that
um
well you know practice makes perfect as
they say I'm sorry practice makes
perfect as they say okay
tomorrow's another day I guess right
tomorrow's
yeah
what was your drug last night
next
mixture of crystal meth and what
and um
I know I was thinking uh
shouldn't take you this long to answer
um
and um
just like you know Smithers Little
Things
you need a miracle that's all I know
yeah
thanks for stopping by Rebecca
you sure you don't want to
foreign
when you're in this state of mind you
won't finish your sentences
so you'll try to have a conversation but
you won't
get past like the first three words of a
sentence
assuming that everyone that I can read
your mind
let's go have a sex change
like no wonder you can't get anything
you want who's going to give you a sex
change or anything
in this in this in this frame in this
state of mind and you're like this most
the time
my audience my audience doesn't see it
because what they see are the very
you on your very best
that's what that's what I show
but this is this is the Rebecca that
usually
exists on the street
and that's why I can't get on board with
you having a sex change
or anything else
the drug use is just too out of control
all right come by tomorrow we'll try
again
foreign
how are your things
again for doing well how are you
I'm good
looks like you had a rough night
strange night ups and downs I don't know
how are you doing I'm great
you're always concerned about me
yeah I know
it's nice thanks
what happened last night
I don't know honestly I was just kind of
walking around I don't know have you
slept
um
what are we gonna do
I'm just gonna get high until we until
something terrible happens
well I mean it seems like you've almost
got a death wish
I know no
I'm just don't know where this lifestyle
is going to take you
great places I think
your goal right now for today it's a
Saturday your goal for today is to what
find some money to get drugs to get high
yeah
Parties by myself I don't know Wanna
Party by yourself
no not alone
thank you
good
how are you doing Mark what have you
been up to
you uh you found some interesting
clothes
it's a beautiful dress
thank you just kind of
where do you find that where'd you find
that
uh I don't really know I can't remember
have you eaten
um
earlier um
sometimes I wonder if you eat and sleep
Rebecca you need a miracle
you need some kind of miracle
I feel like things are gonna get better
very soon things are gonna get better
soon yeah
what's gonna happen that's gonna make
your life better
um yeah yeah um
what's wrong mark
confused about what to do with you
you don't seem to be into going to a
rehab
I know I just I'd rather go to Hollywood
what's in Hollywood what's in Hollywood
so every day is grandchares celebrities
I don't think you're gonna find
celebrities up in Hollywood
they're on the streets that you're
hanging out on
did you ever call Kenneth Kenneth
huh I gave you can Kenneth's phone
number
let me guess you lost your phone
you sold your phone I didn't saw it I
have like a with some Android now
I don't know I don't know Rebecca
you're frustrating
why
because I don't know what I can do to
help you out
I know I just really need like
any of my things like my
I I need to like
you need to
get some math and another phone
you know and another wig
like usual
right
no
one that I need like my uh
like uh
like you don't got back on my peeps and
stuff you know what I mean I'm sorry got
back on my peeps and stuff you know you
want to get back to your peeps your
peeps are in Hollywood
um yeah all over yeah
all right
I'll get you wherever you need to go
thanks Mark
thanks for coming by and saying hi
think about the offer in Florida
I'm hoping I'm hoping you change your
mind on that
um